hey everyone what's going on what's good
welcome to Market takes I know you could
have been anywhere in the world but you
are here with me and I just want to let
you know I appreciate you I am Dion
Robert Bowen host of Market takes and
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
listen there's a lot going on right now
in the world we are trying to break down
the state of things what you need to
watch for this upcoming week we're going
to talk about jobs because of course it
is jobs report week uh the credit crunch
right now that a lot of folks are
worried about in the banking sphere and
the possible recession things that
people are looking out for that are
going to tell us how close or How likely
a recession is we're gonna get some hard
dat on that we're not just going to talk
we're really going to look into the data
so we're going to dive into all of that
before we get into this week's non-farm
payrolls report which is of course the
Big Kahuna of the report this week we're
also going to talk about first the state
of business we are going to talk about
how this credit crunch could be worrying
some folks about the likelihood of of
recession and we're going to talk about
just some of the data that we're going
to get that's going to tell us about
Banks pulling back on some lending and
some other important pieces there second
we are going to get some data on the
health of the consumer I've got a big
report coming out that I've been telling
you guys to watch out for for months
each month that has come in it has been
a little bit more worrisome we're going
to get the latest update on that later
this week and third of course jobs we
have four count them four big reports
coming out this week on the U.S labor
market that are going to tell us a lot
of very important things so these are
the three things that you need to be
watching out for this week we're going
to get into all of them what they are
and what they mean right now so let's
first start off with the state of
business now so there are some worries
that U.S lending is going to slow
because of bank run fears right these
fears of what happened with Silicon
Valley Bank Signature Bank Credit Suisse
Deutsche Bank we've seen it really
reverberate around the world want to
throw something up here on your screen
to just kind of illustrate what a lot of
people have been worried about now what
you're seeing right now is the fed's
senior loan officer opinion survey and
this just is basically the percentage of
banks that say they are tightening their
lending standards what that means is
they are making it harder to give out
loans requiring more from people maybe
it's higher credit scores maybe it's
more collateral basically just saying
we're making it a bit tougher because
we're worried about lending money out
now that number you see there at the
edge of your screen the latest number
where we are that's about 45 percent of
banks saying they are tightening lending
standards making it harder to give out
loans we are already in the area which
typically historically if you look on
your screen there you see all those
little shaded areas that no recession
every time we get to the level that we
are at right now a level that we were at
in January we haven't this isn't even
where we are right now this is before
this banking crisis issue we have had a
recession so that's why this survey is
very informative it tells you about
historical Trends we have seen going
back all the way 30 years the study
started in the 1990s in agency when we
get to the levels that we're right now
there has been a recession every single
time so I wanted to just put that on
your screen to illustrate the historical
trend of this survey and why it's been a
fairly accurate predictor of recessions
now here's the data that we get this
week because that survey the update to
that doesn't come out until May we are
going to get this morning we already got
the U.S manufacturing PMI that actually
was up from the previous month still
below 50 so still showing a contraction
but moving in the right directions there
have been some worries about U.S
manufacturing a lot of surveys on
manufacturing have been just in the
gutter for quite some time Global
manufacturing has showed that it's
picked up we will get another report on
the global manufacturing PMI this
morning in just about an hour at 11 A.M
eastern time and we also get the reports
on Services U.S Services PMI and Global
Services PMI that's Wednesday and
Thursday PMI surveys purchasing managers
indexes basically are where these
companies go out and they say to
businesses hey how are you doing are you
ordering more are you ordering less are
you hiring more hiring less are things
costing more costing less and then they
put together a sentiment index 50
anything above 50 mean things are going
well they're improving anything below 50
means they're getting worse we will get
a bunch of those out this week and in
fact we just got one this morning came
in just below 50 for the U.S
manufacturing sector showing that things
are still getting a little bit worse but
improving from where they were also on
Tuesday we get Factory orders which is
exactly what it sounds like What
factories are ordering then we get U.S
trade balance the U.S trade balance
report that comes out on Wednesday last
month we saw that orders declined
because there were less Imports also
less exports so the the U.S trade
balance decreased but it was just
because there was less overall business
being conducted not necessarily what you
want a big thing coming up this week the
if imf's spring meetings the
international the international monetary
fund uh they're having their financial
stability report released Wednesday and
IMF managing director crystalina
georgieva will be having her press
conference kicking off the spring
meetings that's on Thurs is that if you
want to know about the state of global
business business around the globe you
want to you're going to want to tune
into those on Wednesday and Thursday and
finally on Thursday we get the fed's
discount window borrowing for the
previous week we have seen the FED
pushing out billions hundreds of
billions of dollars back into these
Banks to help sturdy them up we are
going to get the latest update on that
the FED has been trying to reduce its
balance sheet trying to tighten up the
economy through its quantitative
tightening well they're doing that at
the same time as they're pushing a bunch
of money back out in the economy we'll
get the latest report on that on
Thursday now the second thing the state
of the consumer we have seen that
consumers are loading up on debt we will
get the latest report on consumer credit
on Friday that's going to be big it's
going to give us the February numbers
now here's why that matters we did a
report or a video on this a month or two
ago called uh what is it credit card
debt I'm sorry it's credit card debt is
hitting credit card delinquencies excuse
me are skyrocketing now what that video
came out about a month ago we're going
to link to it on the page on the VOD so
you can watch it there but we are seeing
increased defaults by businesses we're
seeing increased delinquency rates by
individuals basically people are taking
on a bunch of debt and a bunch of credit
that they can't afford and they're
starting to go delinquent same thing is
happening with businesses we're not
reaching levels that are worrisome yet
it's still a small number of people but
the increase has been very rapid one of
the fastest increased rates in history
we break all that down in the video so
make sure you check that out now the
third big theme this week jobs
jobs jobs and it's all about jobs not
just about the state of the economy but
for what's going to go on with inflation
and a big thing a big piece of that
inflation puzzle has been the jolts
report we will get the latest update on
that Tuesday want to throw something up
here on your screen to kind of show you
what I'm talking about with jobs and
what you're seeing there is the number
of job openings in the jolt survey and
the number of unemployed people and as
you can see the number of job openings
historically had never risen above the
number of unemployed people we are
seeing that now where it not only is it
are there more job openings than there
are unemployed people there's about two
to one there's about two openings for
every unemployed person that hasn't
moved yet you see there at the edge of
your screen that number not really going
higher not really going lower they're
staying about stagnant fed share Jerome
Palace highlighted this and said hey
this is a problem for the economy it's
giving workers a little too much
leverage giving them leaving them more
leverage to negotiate higher raises
higher pay increases when they start a
new job and that's going to keep
inflation High the FED needs to bring
inflation back down basically the
problem is consumers have money and when
they have money they go out and spend
and so even when companies are raising
prices increasing prices over and over
consumers keep paying and that's what
pushes inflation higher so fed has been
watching this you should watch it Jules
reported on Tuesday this chart just kind
of illustrating the overall theme that
we've seen with job openings and
unemployed people that's big we also get
the ADP report for March that's out on
Wednesday and then we get also on
Thursday the Challenger job Cuts report
want to throw this up on your screen
really quickly to illustrate the theme
that we've seen through the Challenger
job Cuts now you see low low low low low
low levels of cuts those are layoffs and
then boom you see a pick up there
towards the end we saw in the March
report a 410 increase over the year
before in February we saw a 440 increase
over the year before so big pickups in
the Challenger job cuts and that just
kind of illustrates the overall theme of
layoffs we are starting to see a pickup
in layoffs and of course last but
certainly not least we get the non-farm
payrolls report from the government U.S
labor department putting that out on
Friday we will be right here on Market
take so be here with us and and you know
what get your fill we'll be talking
about what the markets are doing how the
markets are responding and get you
caught up on everything that you need to
know for that day so listen that's going
to do it for us here on Market takes
like I said I know you could have been
anywhere in the world you could have
been knocking at the door next door with
those people but you were right here
with me on Market takes and I hope
you'll be with us on Friday we'll see
you then on Market takes